hey guys I'm Brent rose tech writer and
gentle assassin Elon Musk just announced
Tesla's first home battery product he
thinks it's going to change the way the
world consumes and stores energy let's
break this down so you can sound smarter
your weekend barbecue first off let's
talk about the product itself Tesla's
power wall is basically a big lithium
ion battery it's about four feet tall
three feet wide and seven inches deep it
looks kind of like the monolith the
monkeys worshiped in 2001 a Space
Odyssey
now Tesla isn't the first company to
offer home batteries but they're selling
it for about a third the price of the
competitors and they say it'll last a
lot longer it comes in two different
flavors there's a 10 kilowatt hour
version for 3500 bucks which is
basically used as backup power in case
you have an outage or there's the 7
kilowatt hour version for 3000 this
one's meant for daily cycling that means
powering up and depleting that power
every single day running your house off
of it basically the unit is sleek enough
that can be mounted to the wall inside
your garage or even an exterior wall on
your house they can be lined up side by
side by side to match the power
requirements of your home it also comes
in several different colors in case you
want it to match that pretty model su
got inside your garage Tesla is also
going to be selling an infinitely
scalable 100 kilowatt hour power pack
but that's just for utility companies
and commercial purposes so let's leave
that aside for today so why is this a
big deal well solar energy can obviously
only be generated when the Sun is out in
the middle of the day however peak
energy consumption happens at night when
there's no potential for solar energy so
all that energy we generate during the
day essentially goes to waste
what this system does is it gives us a
way to store that energy to then be used
later when we turn the lights on run the
dishwasher and watch TV if you have
enough solar panels the system has the
potential to take you completely off the
grid now you don't have to have solar
panels to use the power wall because you
can use the grid to charge it up to one
theoretical benefit could be charging it
up during off-peak hours when
electricity is cheapest and then running
your home off of it during the peak
evening hours when electricity prices go
up that said given the current price of
the batteries we just don't see the cost
benefit here the place where it would
make sense is if you lived in a blackout
prone region the ability to charge up
when you did have power and then run
your home off the batteries when the
grid goes down could be a real lifesaver
but what if you used these things plus
solar to get completely off the grid how
much money could you save well the
average u.s. household uses about 30
kilowatt hours per day or just over
10,000 900 kilowatt hours per year so
let's say you get four of Tesla's seven
kilowatt hour batteries at three
thousand a piece that's $12,000 for the
batteries alone now the average cost of
electricity in the US is roughly 13
cents per kilowatt hour so you would
need to use roughly 92 thousand 300
kilowatt hours before you broke even on
the cost of the batteries and the
average rate of consumption that's eight
and a half years before this thing pays
for itself and that doesn't account for
the cost of installation of maintenance
of the price of an inverter which would
be thousands or for the gradual
decreasing efficiency of a lithium ion
battery over the course of its lifetime
again these are just averages but
currently this is not something that's
going to save most Americans any money
and that's not even factoring in the
cost of solar panels that said if you
live in a place where energy is more
expensive you would break even sooner
for example in Hawaii the cost per
kilowatt hour is a whopping 37 cents at
that rate it would only take about three
years to recoup the cost of the battery
which is approaching reasonable
ultimately if you're just trying to save
money then this isn't the way to go yet
but if you've got the cash to spend and
you live in a sunny area then the
concept of being able to live
independently of the power grid has a
lot of Appeal so what do you think is
this really the beginning of an energy
revolution or is this just Tesla trying
to sell more batteries to justify the
existence of its gigafactory
let us know what you think in the
comments and don't forget to subscribe
to Wired thanks for watching
you